TERRY RYAN: Today we're
talking about serverless
Spark, limitless data, baseball,
and enterprise learning.
I'm Terry, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Earlier this year we
made serverless Spark
generally available,
creating the industry's
first autoscaling
serverless Spark.
And now we're taking
it a step further
and making serverless
Spark even more
powerful by enabling serverless
interactive development
through Jupyter Notebooks,
natively integrated
with Vertex AI Workbench.
Now a data scientist will
not need to provision
any infrastructure in advance.
They can just start
developing on demand.
With the dramatic
growth in the amount
and types of data,
workloads, and users,
we are at a point where
traditional data architectures,
even when deployed in the
cloud, are unable to unlock
its full potential.
As a result, the
data-to-value gap is growing.
To address these
challenges, we're
unveiling several
data cloud innovations
that allow customers to
work with limitless data
across all workloads,
and extend access
to everyone, from BigLake
and Spanner change streams
to Vertex AI Workbench
and model registry.
Check out the blog for more.
Baseball and
statistics go way back.
These days cloud
technology enables
MLB to collect and analyze
25 million unique data points
from each of its 2,430
regular season games.
From helping players
improve their performance
to bringing fans
closer to the action,
we'll walk you through
a few ways MLB is
hitting a grand slam with data.
There are countless
reasons why enterprises
are moving to the cloud,
from reduced IT costs
to improved security
and efficiency.
But how will organizations
accelerate cloud adoption
within their organizations?
The answer is
comprehensive training.
Google Cloud Skills Boost
combines award-winning learning
experiences with the
ability to earn credentials
to validate learning, which
can be managed and delivered
directly by Google Cloud with
enterprise-level features.
Learn more about our
research-driven courses
and how you can get
started on the blog.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.